sapete ragazzi la cosa curiosa quale due
settimane fa avevo fatto il video su
questa roba qua dovevo trovare cinque
minuti per trovare un altro posto per
toglierlo da dallo sfondo dei video per
campo brutto è che in due settimane ho
avuto la pigrizia di non spostarlo di un
centimetro
vabbè delle tutti ragazzi benvenuti a
questo momento sono fa vj ed oggi siamo
in un nuovo blog e prima di cominciare
come al solito dire di partire con la
frase a settimana che questa settimana è
stata vinta da chi in acqua che ha fatto
questa cosa geniale mi mette
inquietudine solo a vederlo mischia
inquietudine ho imparato un nuovo
termine è un bel giorno questo quando
siamo andati al tomorrowland due
settimane fa abbiamo anche avuto un
giorno libero per visitare un po
bruxelles ho fatto anche alcuni video
quindi niente ve li lascio perché non li
avevo ancora messi buona visione
dipende da tutti ragazzi ed a tutti i
ragazzi ecco perche temono sotto la
ruota gigante ma secondo te se ci provo
ce la faccio io aprendo i bambini e li
lanci dentro le rane lanciare bambina
quale l'attesa che spiega il gioco
questo è ciò che into lanciare pump in
egitto nella sanità
finché voglio attestare la difficoltà di
questa cosa
è grave ok ma adesso in ginocchio non è
fatta il bambino però provano ne face
bambine proprio tra ragazzi niente o
lega non è possibile è tornata indietro
però da qua qua ragazzi prende il
signore vinci 1000 punti 100 punti non
ha mai vinto i bambini ne hanno vinti
300 io ne ho vinti cento
c'è veramente scritto certo punto e di
scuse ma dato questa che va bene andiamo
a fare sto prendete ten di ruote 6
emozionate per questa favorito smith è
enorme ma sicura dobbiamo limon arci
quando arriviamo in cima si assicuri che
sia sicuro perché c'è solo questo
sportellino che si tiene
è la madonna il cazzo c'è un elefante ci
sono i suoni della natura dentro la cruz
si balla stai calma necessaria questa
voce da nazista tedesco
no ragazzi ma la cosa divertente che
tornati in aeroporto il giorno della
partenza tomorrowland è finito siamo in
aeroporto c'è un cazzo di dj set in
aeroporto ma che chi touch ma perché
anche in aeroporto sant armi in bambù
rehn
[Musica]
e lì è bellissimo allora ragazzi
passiamo le news
mi spiego sto per dirvi la news della
vita della vita dove la dovete essere
pronti voi non capite
allora ragazzi avete presente che intera
pinoli film del quale ha fatto parte che
è uscito tipo l'anno scorso praticamente
mi hanno detto mi hanno detto che il
film ovviamente solo sono comprati il
giappone e la corea cosa significa
significa che in tutti i cinema del
giappone e della corea daranno gente
veramente cioè non sto scherzando cielo
ri doppieranno in giapponese tutto
quanto la cosa [ __ ] e che hanno già
fatto la locandina e ve la faccio vedere
perché ce l'ho e questa sembra
bellissimo genova immaginate una casa di
scena dell'inter ap doppiata in
giapponese
ma perché non lo siamo un'altra giorno
io che amo gli animi europa del gene per
me essere doppiato in giapponese e un
cazzo di onore non ci voglio credere mai
nella fitta c'è ha detto ero tipo
veramente peccato si chiama the virtual
east che l'hanno cambiato il nome che
tra l'altro è 10 volte meglio il nome
the virtual east che quello di prima
anzi da ragionati io ho fatto the
virtual iss che poi bellissimo che la
copertina italiana era questa che ci
stavamo io de carli zoda e clapis in
quella giapponese ci sta solo io e gli
altri sei sono cariati di striscio ma
perché vale ragazzi volevo dirvi st
cagata passiamo avanti questi giorni vi
state sbagliando tantissimo un segreto
che gira in questi giorni appunto su in
segreto leggiamoli insieme dollari 14
anni ogni volta che vedo un video di
fari jaime ma se così tanto che ho messo
la faccia stampata di fa vj su un
peluche
gli ho fatto il pene e mi sono auto
vabbè interessante hoc ragazzi quando
siamo andati a tomorrow when c'è una
cosa che non vi ho detto a tomorrowland
ci sono i dj più famosi del mondo che
fanno i dj set
non so se lo sapete ma quando un dj fa
un dj set al tomorrowland fanno proprio
il video fatto bene dove riprendono dj e
riprendono tutta quanta la folla poi il
video viene preso e caricato sul canale
del tomorrowland dove fa milioni
io volevo comparire nel dj set di
cashmere cherasco cristiano qui che sono
andato a vedere e per l'occasione mi ero
messo davanti c'è io ero davanti a tutta
la folla perché ogni tanto i cameramen
vanno lì vicino e riprendono dopo la
gente da vicino che si vede proprio nel
video che ti prendi prendono proprio
come come mi sto riprendendo gli adesso
io ho passato tutto quanto il set di
cashmere assaltare a urlare come un
ossesso in un'ora e mezza tra sudore
ascellare palestinese e iraniano
mischiati insieme e indovinate un po chi
cazzo è finito nel video di cashmere
eccolo lì a per fabbricare si arriva
attenzione attenzione
ecco lo è non aspetta lui che cazzo
c'entra ma perché lo red baco ragazzo
c'entrava lui si stanziano regala
ripreso la ripreso lui che sta dietro
bello bello non sarei chi cazzo e
cashmere lo chiamava champagne
in realtà ci sono finito anch'io nel
video è per carità c'è o meglio i miei
fottuti i capelli solo quello cioè mi si
vede così prima di concludere di farvi
la favino manda voleva annunciarvi
ragazzi che la prossima settimana ci
sarà un video speciale con uno youtuber
speciale una youtube ma vabbè dai come
fai domanda provate a indovinare chi era
youtuber online su berdyev a me mi sto
già [ __ ] con la frase di prima quindi
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto che
come al solito servito piaciuta sono un
commento è un beat live anche la pagina
di facebook e come liquido torta nella
descrizione senza questi dischetti lì ci
rivediamo il prossimo video per ragazzi